we have a phrase in England he doesn't
know his ass from his elbow yeah we know
that we have yeah yeah um it's for an
incompetent person he doesn't want their
do it was after was out but you would
have to be in confidence and not know
that wouldn't imagine that yeah it
wouldn't stand up in court
yeah would know you go by pants I
thought it was their elbow no you didn't
but that but believe it or not they can
look similar if you just take a little
selfie right we're all do this right
what's this right all right and we get a
game called a sore elbow yeah if you
want so okay I'll just take a picture
okay oh my
clearly my elbow yeah yeah this is
clearly when you sort of manipulate it
and sort of crop it just right look at
that
I just you could just put little random
things in there right right what can I
help you in any way just anything
anything makes it look just a little bit
yeah I want it for medical right look at
this right this is so you can eat peanut
butter Nutella yeah
my mate showed me that and he's a
classical musician we did that for about
three hours it's great just do it you
should do this we're gonna do it's gonna
be winner you'd be great you'd be all
you have a great
I love anyone tuning in just now there's
ripping and he does no time
oh that's amazing Andy that is beautiful
all that he's got the double flap going
on that is
[Applause]
you change examine ladies and gentlemen
it's a whole new Conan show from now on
a sore elbow Madeleine Albright